[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes directeur du patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO et vous avez eu une
phrase un jour que je trouve absolument
magnifique vous avez dit
je ne suis pas là pour préserver des
pierres parce que ce qu'on préserve
c'est la vie
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là
c'est pour expliquer que quand on parle
du patrimoine on parle de ce qui définit
toutes les sociétés
humanité les sociétés tout ce qui est
vivant tout ce qui nous permet de nous
identifier
que nous sommes des humains que nous
appartenons à différentes régions du
monde et que nous avons toute une
histoire et c'est cette diversité
culturelle qui se reflète à travers le
patrimoine et donc quand on préserve le
patrimoine non seulement on préserve
toute cette identité toute cette
diversité plurielle de ce qui constitue
le monde mais on préserve aussi la vie
parce que c'est cette vie là qui fait
que nous pouvons nous mélanger nous
pouvons nous comprendre et dont nous
pouvons promouvoir la paix vous
prononcer le mot de paix vous avez
absolument besoin du multilatéralisme
c'est à dire que il faut que tout le
monde soit autour de la table cela c'est
essentiel justement pour préserver ces
pierres et pour faire en sorte que la
vie perdure bah oui parce que le
multilatéralisme permet de mettre des
choses en commun et de se donner des
missions précises qui permettent de
régler des questions fondamentales dans
les domaines dans le domaine de
l'éducation le domaine de la culture en
particulier et c'est aussi pourquoi le
multilatéralisme ici est important aussi
pour la préservation du patrimoine
mondial alors quand on pense au
patrimoine on pense beaucoup pierre au
monument mais c'est aussi des paysages
c'est des paysages c'est pour ça que
j'ai l'habitude de dire que à la fois
les monuments sont importants comme
Notre Dame c'est à Paris ou la Tour
Eiffel ou mais ce qui est aussi
important c'est ce qui permet de
comprendre comment les différentes
sociétés
occupent un territoire
et à travers ce territoire là le
transforme et ce qui permet qu'il
s'identifie à celui et préserve leur
culture donc c'est pour ça que les
paysages culturels sont très importants
et ça façonne la culture de chaque
peuple non seulement ça la façon mais ça
permet de mieux la comprendre et de la
partager c'est aussi ce qui nous
intéresse le plus c'est pas simplement
de se focaliser à comprendre comment on
la façon mais surtout à partager et à
partager surtout les messages qui sont
très importants qui sont en fait les
messages d'universalité pourquoi il y a
si peu de sites de monuments de bien
culturels qui soient inscrit au
patrimoine mondial et qui proviennent
d'Afrique
alors si j'avais une réponse
très claire je pense que on aurait déjà
réglé la question mais nous avons essayé
de comprendre ce qui s'est passé depuis
que les premiers sites ont été inscrits
sur la Liste du patrimoine mondial il
faut savoir que c'était comment ça en
1978 d'accord parce que la Convention du
patrimoine mondial qui permettait
justement l'inscription des sites au
patrimoine mondial a étant adopté en
1972 donc 6 ans après
ce principe de de liste du patrimoine
mondial a commencé à accueillir des
premiers sites il faut dire que dans ces
premiers sites il y avait des sites
africains alors par la suite cela peut
s'expliquer par la nécessité d'abord de
mettre en place un nombre de politiques
pour mieux les identifier ces sites en
Afrique et il faut dire que à ce moment
là certaines régions comme comme
l'Europe en elle commençait à proposer
un peu plus de sites parce que les
professionnels étaient déjà formés des
politiques de préservation du patrimoine
avait déjà été mise en place alors que
dans certaines régions se représentées
aujourd'hui ce processus commençait et
voilà un peu comment l'écart s'est
creusé et c'est cet écart là qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui essayer de
rattraper et réduire combien y a-t-il de
sites
inscrits au Patrimoine mondial qui sont
Africains si on parle de l'Afrique
continentale avec Maurice et Madagascar
en comptant aussi la partie nord de
l'Afrique
on est à un total de 139
sites qui sont inscrits sur la liste sur
conviviale sur un total de 1157 il y a
un retard terrible et alors quand on
prend que l'Afrique subsaharienne il y
en a que 98 donc les carrés quand même
important et lorsqu'on sait qu'en même
temps cet Afrique regorge d'une
incroyable richesse
de patrimoine qui mériterait un jour de
rejoindre la liste du patrimoine mondial
on se rend compte que il faut y accorder
une attention particulière aujourd'hui
pour aider les pays africains à mettre
en place les politiques à former des
professionnels qui pourraient non
seulement les gérer non seulement les
préserver mais aussi préparer les
dossiers pour les proposer pour
candidatures au patrimoine mondial alors
je crois savoir qu'il y a une école qui
s'est constituée au Bénin une école du
patrimoine africain non et l'école du
patrimoine africain existe d'ailleurs
c'est une excellente chose aujourd'hui
que des profits de temps je crois oui
puisse aller se former plus se former en
Afrique et c'est au Bénin que ça se
passe il faut encourager c'est au Bénin
aujourd'hui cette école il y en a une
autre qui a qui au Kenya pour les pays
anglophones mais il faudrait encourager
le développement de de ce type
d'institutions de formation
professionnelle pour former de plus en
plus de professionnels pas simplement
pour le patrimoine matériel ou matériel
aussi pour la préservation des musées
pour la lutte contre le trafic et les
sites
sont importantes alors la préservation
des identités deux choses
en termes de bien culturels et de
monuments qu'est-ce qu'on peut recenser
qu'est-ce qu'il y a il y a les pyramides
de Gizeh j'imagine il y a la prison de
Robin Island qu'est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres on avait cité certaines qui
sont
assez extraordinaires que l'on ne peut
pas visiter mais aussi quand on regarde
le reste de l'Afrique si on va par
exemple au Sénégal on va on va aller
voir l'île de Gorée
ou l'ancienne ville de Saint-Louis et un
peu plus loin la petite un petit pays
comme la Gambie qui est à l'île de James
is ce qu'on appelle l'île de Kunta Kinte
qui est assez importante et si on
traverse une partie de l'Afrique et
qu'on se retrouve en Afrique de l'Est en
Éthiopie vous avez des sites importants
comme la libella on peut descendre même
un peu plus bas en Afrique austral au
même aux Zimbabwe par exemple donc vous
avez le Grand Zimbabwe et alors je peux
vous en citer beaucoup mais qui sont pas
simplement des monuments mais qui sont
aussi qui sont aussi des sites
et des paysages comme par exemple
le Kilimanjaro ou encore un peu au Kenya
des forêts sacrées mais incroyables les
forêts de musique kenda par exemple
qu'on ne qu'on ne connaît pas mais qu'il
faudrait de plus en plus connaître ou
alors les paysages culturels de conso
aussi en Éthiopie il y a aussi des des
forêts préservées qui sont qui sont très
très
importantes en République démocratique
du Congo par exemple ou même à
Madagascar avec des des forêts primaires
très importantes
il y a beaucoup de sites aussi il faut
le dire qui sont menacés par la guerre
qui sont menacés par le réchauffement
climatique comment préserver tout ça et
notamment vous avez beaucoup peuvré
vous-même d'ailleurs personnellement à
ton bouquetou au Mali ou pays en guerre
pour préserver et bien les manuscrits de
Tombouctou ou les mausolées aussi de
tout comment vous avez fait pour essayer
de préserver tout ça de la guerre et des
ravages des attaques djihadistes d'abord
vous avez raison de dire aujourd'hui que
le patrimoine mondial est de plus en
plus
menacé par
certains dangers comme les guerres les
conflits armés qui qui font que le
patrimoine est détruit et ça c'est
quelque chose de terrible et
l'une des grandes
particularité du concept de patrimoine
mondial c'est que quand le patrimoine
est en danger et détruit la communauté
internationale se mobilise pour essayer
de préserver ce patrimoine parce qu'il
n'est pas simplement important pour les
pays en question mais il est un
patrimoine de l'humanité donc il est
important parce qu'il raconte l'histoire
de notre humanité c'est ce qui s'est
passé effectivement avec Tombouctou une
ville
[Musique]
millénaire comme comme celle-là où il y
a eu une université au 15e siècle ou
beaucoup d'érudits
à prendre venez apprendre et où il y a
eu un centre intellectuel très important
avec une production non seulement de de
manuscrits dont certains sont
scientifiques assez important et qui en
arabe et aussi des centres un centre
religieux et c'est pour ça que les
mausolées auxquels les populations
étaient attachées et était important à
préserver parce que sans ces mausolée
c'est ça allait être la complète
déstructuration d'une vie sociale qui a
été préservée depuis le 11e siècle ouais
jusqu'à ce jour extraordinaire et ça
c'est important et à côté de
ce danger
qui la destruction du patrimoine en
période de confirmé
on a aussi ce phénomène du changement
climatique pour les manuscrits de
Tombouctou ils ont été transportés en
voiture comment ça s'est passé la nuit
comment vous avez fait pour échapper
justement à la menace djihadiste alors
d'abord ça a été une initiative
incroyable des
communautés de Tombouctou des villageois
en fait non mais de ces groupes qui
étaient à Tombouctou et qui préservait
eux-mêmes déjà
de leur famille d'accord et qui se sont
rendus compte que cette trésor qu'ils
avaient hérité de leur famille qui
montrait que leurs ancêtres avaient été
des des grands intellectuels qui avaient
contribué au développement de cette
ville à son rayonnement n'avait pas
envie de les perdre et il nous disait
toujours que perdre les manuscrits et
les mausolées c'était un peu comme
perdre leurs deux poumons donc perdre la
vie et au péril de leur vie
ces communautés ont sorties ces
manuscrits de la ville de la ville pour
aller les cacher à Bamako un peu plus
elles ont sorti près de 400 000
manuscrits
de temps au péril de leur ville c'était
quelquefois à dos d'âne pour sortir les
pirogues jusqu'à Mopti et après
continuer par la voiture par la route
voilà heureusement beaucoup d'entre de
ces manuscrits ont été préservés mais on
en a quand même perdu
plus de 4000 manuscrits parce que
certains ont été brûlés
et certains étaient volés est-ce que
c'est une région c'est elle qui est très
menacée et beaucoup de pays en Afrique
malheureusement par l'islamisme est-ce
que le patrimoine peut être menacé par
justement une idéologie qui cherche à
remettre en question la culture
ancestrale que souvent beaucoup de pays
c'est ce que nous avons
observé à Tombouctou
une communauté
qui vivait
depuis 9 siècles avec une pratique de
l'Islam qui est l'Islam Sophie
et qui de toute façon avait cette
habitude là à la fois de pratiquer
l'islam mais aussi de rendre hommage à
leurs ancêtres qui avaient contribué au
développement de la ville et avec une
occupation de Tombouctou à partir de
2012 par des groupes armés et des
groupes extrémistes amenant une autre
idéologie
ils ont cherché à stopper cette
continuité de pratiques culturelles et
de et religieuse et pour cela il fallait
détruire le patrimoine comme étant ce
symbole important
qui était important pour ces communautés
et grâce aux habitants ils n'ont pas
réussi à le faire ils ont quand même
détruit les mausolées que l'UNESCO a
reconstruit moi j'ai eu une chance
énorme et le privilège d'être
celui que l'UNESCO a chargé de cette
œuvre de mener cette stratégie de
reconstruction
avec nos partenaires mais mais ce qui
est surtout important nous avons
reconstruit les mausolées de Tombouctou
avec la pluie des communautés qui
voulaient que leur majolais soit
préservé semble aussi aller un peu plus
loin c'est que nous avons remis à jour
toutes les traditions de maintien de
d'entretien de ces mausolées là
alors tout à l'heure je parlais de la
prison de Robin Island c'est une prison
qui a été fréquentée par un homme qui
est une figure de l'Afrique pour
toujours qui est Nelson Mandela parce
que il était interdé dans cette ce
centre pénitentiaire au bail Island
c'est une île
au large de l'Afrique du Sud donc il y a
été interné pendant 17 ans une partie de
sa détention vous avez eu ce privilège
sans doute de connaître cet homme parce
que vous êtes architecte et que à
l'époque vous l'avez connu vous étiez en
charge d'un programme immobilier en
Afrique du Sud à Cape Town je crois
racontez-nous comment ça s'est passé
déjà c'est toujours avec beaucoup
d'émotions que je
me ré mémorce ce moment important
qui vous transforme en tant qu'homme
Nelson Mandela est une icône
de notre monde et j'avais souhaité aller
en Afrique du Sud comme un jeune
architecte
intéressée pour aider
la construction de logements sociaux à
très bas prix et j'avais envie d'aller
contribuer à ce programme de
reconstruction de développement que le
président Nelson Mandela avait lancé
quand il a été élu pour reconstruire
pour donner des logements à un million
de personnes en Afrique
et nous avons avec
l'organisation que je représentais de
relation
cratère qui est basée à l'école
d'architecture de Grenoble
nous avons mis en place une stratégie
qui n'était pas simplement de construire
des logements mais qui était de dire que
nous allions former des personnes qui
avaient vécu la parfaite qui n'avait pas
eu cette opportunité d'aller à l'école
d'accord à des métiers de construction
et ensuite de les accompagner pour
qu'ils deviennent eux-mêmes des
entrepreneurs pour construire d'autres
logements que nous avions en place et
c'était une une idée qui a beaucoup
beaucoup plus au président Nelson
Mandela qui l'a eu envie de venir voir
ce Camerounais qui habitait à islandone
pour venir aider les Sud-Africains
c'était vous et c'était moi et il est
venu et nous avons visité je lui ai
montré un peu tout ce que nous faisions
dans un tramship donc un chip c'est un
centre urbain réservé aux Noirs
il était venu pour 15 minutes et
finalement avec tout ce que je lui
montrais et que les explications je lui
donnais il a envie eu envie de passer
encore plus de temps et nous sommes
restés deux heures ensemble à boire du
thé d'accord parler d'autre chose et ces
moments où vous marre parce que il a été
par des mots
de très très encourageant en montrant
effectivement que ce que nous faisions
était important pour le peuple d'Afrique
du Sud et que lui il en est vraiment été
non seulement très content
mais fier que ce soit un Africain qui
fait ça qui viennent aider d'autres
Africains en Afrique du Sud quand vous
passez du temps avec un homme que vous
n'espérez pas connaître ou rencontrer un
jour et qui vous montre finalement qu'il
est aussi simple que vous et moi et par
ces attitudes et l'attention qu'il vous
porte à ce moment-là
vous donne une façon de regarder la vie
et ça vous transforme dans la manière
dont vous devez servir les autres
c'est ce qui m'a beaucoup apporté et qui
m'a amené certainement à poursuivre ma
carrière avec Nelson Mandela comme un
grand modèle aujourd'hui vous êtes
directeur du patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO d'ailleurs vous devez vous
réjouir de voir que les États-Unis
reviennent à l'intérieur de
l'organisation Louisienne mais avant ça
vous avez été chargé aussi de ce qu'on a
appelé l'épisode de la qui est pas
terminé qui est loin d'être terminée des
restitutions d'oeuvres d'art africaines
qui
ont pu être
pillés ou exporter en Europe ou en
Occident ou ailleurs là on voit
d'ailleurs les les statues
d'Abomey au Bénin qui ont été restitués
en 2021 si je ne m'abuse est-ce que
cette restitution pour vous est une
bonne chose
alors la restitution est une bonne chose
en 1978
le l'ancien Directeur général de
l'UNESCO dans le détail générale de
l'époque Amadou matambo qui était
sénégalais qui était sénégalais avait
lancé un appel pour la restitution des
biens culturels au pays et à ceux qui
les avaient créés ça veut donc dire que
il s'agissait à ce moment-là d'amener
les États à coopérer pour que les pays
qui souhaitaient
nos retours et la restitution des
oeuvres importantes
pour leur peuple puisse dialoguer afin
que ce retour soit possible donc la
restitution quand elle aboutit est une
très bonne chose est-ce que ça répare le
passé qui est un passé colonial qui est
un passé parfois très douloureux
alors l'idée de la restitution est pas
de réparer le passé l'idée de la
restitution est d'aider et de construire
l'avenir et de renforcer la coopération
j'ai toujours pour habitude de dire que
il s'agit pas que les pays africains
disent vous avez pris des objets ben
rendez les nous il s'agit de dire
contribuer à notre nouvelle manière
de préparer l'avenir de nos pays parce
que c'est une façon de se construire
c'est une façon de renforcer la
coopération et bien sûr pas de se
construire parce que il y a pas que les
États africains qui demandent le retour
de phénomène si on américaine
oui c'est ça donc c'est cette
coopération qui est aujourd'hui
importante et d'ailleurs les
professionnels africains sont très
claires là dessus il ne demande pas
le retour de tous les objets il demande
le retour des objets qui leur sont les
plus significatifs pour aider non
seulement à la recherche pour aider à
l'éducation de ceux qui ne peuvent pas
venir les regarder ces gens aussi mais
aussi au tourisme au développement
économique il y a beaucoup de trafic
d'oeuvres d'art en Afrique
le trafic illicite est un phénomène
mondial
alors il y a le trafic illicite bien
culturels
partout parce que c'est c'est un
commerce c'est un commerce illicite et
qui rapporte
mais c'est en période de conflit et de
guerre c'est encore beaucoup plus grave
on a vu
le trafic les sites des biens culturels
au nord du Mali des biens qui sont
partis ont des sites archéologiques qui
sont pillés en Libye aussi sans doute on
en a vu aussi en Libye on a vu un Irak
et en Syrie et dans tous ses biens se
retrouvent sur le marché à des prix
exorbitants et il faut lutter contre ce
trafic illicite parce que ce n'est pas
que des objets qui partent mais c'est
une partie importante de l'histoire de
de ces pays qui disparaît il faut qu'on
continue de lutter contre ce phénomène
et ce fléau terrible que le trafiqué
décide de bien culturels et
effectivement il y en a en Afrique mais
il y en a partout dans le monde entier
alors deux petites questions pour
terminer quel est votre votre monument
votre site africain préféré
alors évidemment j'ai toujours été
impressionné par tous les sites
africains
mais il y en a un qui m'a le plus marqué
c'est celui où j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps à reconstruire c'est Tombouctou
oui les mausolée pas simplement et même
la ville avec ses trois grandes mosquées
et la mosquée de jingare qui a été
construite en 1325 et qui est toujours
aujourd'hui une des plus grandes
mosquées construite en terre et qui est
incroyablement belle à l'intérieur comme
à l'extérieur parce que c'est un
architecte andalou entre 125 qui était
venu avec Kankan Moussa pour la pour la
construire j'ai aussi des sites qui qui
sont des sites qui nous rappellent à
quel point le l'Afrique c'est une
culture qui est à la femme matérielle et
immatérielle
et c'est les forêts sacrées de
michikanda dont j'ai parlé ou sur un
site comme celui-là quand on le visite
on rentre dans ce site en enlevant ses
chaussures on se reconnecte au lieu
d'une forêt à la terre dans la forêt
sacrée de michikanda au Kenya a pas très
loin de mon bassin c'est-à-dire sur la
côte de l'Océan Indien et je pourrais
vous parler de sabot et je vois
exactement je pourrais vous parler de
d'autres sites aussi qui sont qui sont
importants je sais que je vais faire
peut-être déjà l'eau incitant c'est
encore un alors ces deux sites mais vous
avez aussi l'île de Nelson mandeline
qui vous marque quand vous la visiter et
si vous aviez un écrivain qui vous
inspire
africain ça serait lequel
alors je pense à un écrivain qui est
aujourd'hui disparu qui a écrit un livre
qui s'appelle le soleil des
indépendances
Amadou Kourouma alors ce livre il est un
écrivain ivoirien ivoirien ce livre il
m'a marqué quand je l'ai lu parce que
c'est un livre d'abord qui est écrit
dans les années 70 et qui qui vous fait
un peu
cette on va choisir cette peinture de
l'Afrique des indépendances et comment
un prince malinké Pharma
essaye de s'adapter à cette nouvelle vie
et confronté un peu à ses propres
contradictions et c'est intéressant
parce qu'en même temps il y a des des
questions politiques qui arrivent qui
sont toutes nouvelles mais il y a aussi
le nécessaire besoin de retrouver un peu
toute son histoire qui était une
histoire culturelle et puis c'est
traditions et je crois que beaucoup de
d'entre nous sont un peu dans cette
dualité et ce livre en fait ce roman en
particulier est toujours dit encore un
roman qui va se dire présent et
contemporain d'actualité et d'actualité
et j'aime beaucoup ce que Amadou
Kourouma a écrit dans le soleil des
indépendances merci Lazare et lindou
assombo merci plaisir merci beaucoup
[Musique]